so how do you think they would have made
all these this is when i couldn't watch
it i couldn't handle it this shot's
actually done backwards to get her hair
to flow the right way oh
i forgot how brutal this was just wait
dude
hey happy halloween welcome back to
another episode of visual effects artist
react today we're going to be looking at
some spooky movies kind of like him whoa
so real quick we will be showing some
things with gore but we're doing it from
a making of cinema perspective so this
is the blood you're seeing this is a
bunch of food coloring and corn syrup
any guesses as to as to who i am give me
a hand okay i got you
i know cinema 4d oh you're morpheus uh
close very close i'm the matrix you are
the matrix matrix i'm storm toad i'm
like a storm trooper toad technically
i'm i'm captain phasma phasma toad nico
what are uh what
are you nico um
all right enough of the code breaking
enough of the peasant killing let's get
into these movies i think it was a good
night nope good night
[Laughter]
one of my favorite horror films is a
movie called the cabin in the woods
this is a movie that pays homage to
pretty much every single horror film to
have ever been made it incorporates all
the same like cliches and ideas it's
very obvious that the filmmakers behind
this movie everyone involved loves
horror movies every monster from every
horror movie to have ever been made is
in this warehouse of little prison cells
holding each monster and they're slowly
seeing all the other monsters that are
around them
so this girl
she's just kind of like a fantastical
representation of guillermo del toro's
sort of imagery right okay i got you
this guy this is michael myers oh uh
hellraiser we'll tear your soul apart
hellraiser exactly it's not the same
it's it's actually very different he's
got like these saw blades in his face
this is so dark with these shades like
it's already a dark scene but with these
shades it's just so freaking dark
[Music]
it's a dog cujo
pennywise anaconda
is that left for dead is it a boomer is
that a boomer look at the belly button
it's huge so how do you think they would
have made all these 3d modeling i would
guess they did that for some of the
things they did most of it for real they
actually built out several different
versions of those cube prisons at
different scales oh interesting you have
like the full-sized one that people can
stand inside but then they had smaller
ones that they put regular people in to
make them look huge and then they had
really tiny ones that they actually put
real bugs oh that's so cool creepy yeah
that thing right there look at how gross
that is that's awesome and it's like not
that big but when it's set at the same
size as the same prison that holds
people it looks like this eight foot
wide monster dude all this work for just
one banging shot well technically most
of these monsters get utilized at some
point earlier in the movie earlier on in
this movie there's even a scene from the
video game fear i think the girl's name
is alma
it's an actual movie version of the
video game just for a moment i love fear
yeah such a good game that was like the
first game that like scared the crap out
of me i could name you could not play
that game dude
i want to talk to you guys about one of
the scary movies that scared me the most
as a kid and that was the ring
oh that's cool all your hair like goes
over the lip first of the well rather
than reverse and played it backwards
oh cool okay okay see i'm trying to
think about this movie in the context of
when it came out
oh and this part right here specifically
yeah people lost it
dude that rotoscoping behind his hair no
i know was that actually rotoscoping or
is she there
let's break this down real quick this is
actually a pretty simple effect
basically you have your clean plate here
where they're shooting in this apartment
they're backing the camera up and
they're going to redo the take with the
girl on a green screen crawling through
a square hole that are the exact
dimensions of the television this shot's
actually done backwards to get her hair
to flow the right way so they probably
started with her leaning out and then
she leans back and pulls her arm back to
get her hair done oh yeah yeah of course
because the hair like droops over the tv
in a really interesting way yeah which
is also on the well it's a really nice
subtle touch that throws you off and
makes you think that things are being
otherworldly yeah there's a couple
things that i want to point out it's one
thing to take a tv cut out the glass put
a hole in the back and have your actress
actually like crawl through the hole of
the tv and then you just replace the
background but notice there's two
different versions of her here i think
there's an actual version where she's in
front of a camera and that's comped into
the actual shot of the tv and then it's
a different version of her that's
crawling out of the tv and they matched
it pretty well so when a 3d object
phases through like a wall for instance
it's not just a simple matter of like
fading that person out so what they're
doing here is they're actually manually
being like okay so the front bit of the
haircut is coming through first so that
gets revealed first and slowly wipes
outwards as the rest of her hair comes
through then some glass type distortion
effects at those edges and then they're
rotoing her even when she comes out of
the tv she's being rodeoed and affected
slightly you know to give her that tv
flickery light look there's something
that we haven't pointed out at all yet
look at that tv screen it looks very
good they got the reflections of the
background very nicely reflecting off
the glass of the tv i feel like that's
easy enough to comp a reflection over
top of it it's in the frame for just a
little bit up in the top left corner and
you just reference what that actually
looks like at your tv at home and you
comp it in well i mean that reflection
looks really good it's very good that
looks like glass if we were to do this
now the tv would just be an empty box
and you'd film your actor doing this all
in one shot and you just rotoscope your
actor make them you know black and white
and up the contrast they kind of stand
out and then you just cg back in some
glass on the tv but it's also very
possible that it's just a motion control
rig and they just did it once with the
actual tv there to get the clean shot of
the screen that's a good point though
because then you can preserve all those
real reflections
paranormal activity it has kind of like
a vlog type feel to it this movie deals
with tension brilliantly but also they
have some very simple visual effects in
this movie that really just pound home
the point
little shadow
this is the moment this is when i
couldn't watch it i couldn't handle it
[Music]
[Applause]
is that it yeah that was it i didn't get
scared at all this was my hand
watching that scene with no sound
because i remember how scary it was how
would you have approached this shot nico
i always had a rope around her ankle
dragged her out of bed and then just
erased me in the rope that sounds like
the most low budget solution because
that's probably exactly what they did
there are two ropes one from a person
off to the side pulling her out of bed
and then a second rope that is also
still there pulling her down the hallway
it's a pretty simple paint out it looks
like just some you know to take some
time but like this is the shot of the
movie you can spend a little bit of time
it's just rotoscoping is basically all
it is it's a simple effect they're doing
themselves a favor by shooting at night
like this yeah because the ground is
basically like a couple solid colors
like gradient you know eric beck from
indy mogul did this exact shot there are
no behind the scenes of the movie he's
actually just guessing how they did it
what
it's so well done
this one's better than the movie they
had to make these special ropes just to
like grip her leg without cutting off
circulation yeah so it's pulling on a
wider surface area exactly exactly so
they're hiding most of it with the
sweatpants yeah exactly and that was the
thing is that like i thought i remember
her wearing shorts in that scene but
upon watching it again she's totally
wearing pants which would cover all of
the stuff around the rope okay i mean i
guess if we're looking at this movie we
might as well look at the one actual
digital vfx shot in the movie it's the
final shot
yeah this is this is more just time
lapse footage just record for a long
time have your actors stay very still
that's so creepy just standing over him
watching him sleep ugh
i think this was the moment i couldn't
handle it yeah i remember being super
scared about this moment too because she
starts coming towards the camera you're
just like oh yeah it's coming for me i
couldn't handle this
but then they do the andrew kramer hey
what's up andrew kramer here
demon's face
effect yeah it looks like they almost
had him just jump numerous times and
then all the frames together that's a
fake shadow on the door so i think you
might be right i think that actually is
how they did that just like him kind of
jumping up and just kind of keeping that
shape as similar as possible yeah so he
jumped there and they jumped again there
yeah so orin peli the director of the
movie made the movie for 15 000 and then
when it got picked up other people put
more money into it to make it a
theatrical release and it went on to
make
890 million dollars wow that is a
blockbuster hit this just goes to show
it's like you can make an excellent
movie for almost no money you don't need
to have the best gear in the world to
make a great film blair witch was the
same deal yeah no blair witch was
actually made for
gonna die out of cheaper
would you like to learn how to dodge
bullets would you like to learn how to
jack into the matrix what is the matrix
maybe you want to learn cinema 4d maybe
you want to learn how to do vfx how
would you know the difference between
the dream world
and the real world well subscribe to
this channel because we do a lot of that
stuff are you saying i can render that
shot in 10 minutes i'm saying that when
you're ready nico
you won't have to render anything
definitely subscribe to the channel and
you won't be missing out on anything vfx
related i promise
we'd be wasting our time if we didn't
talk about practical effects in horror
movies and i know this is vfx artist
react but i got to talk about one of my
favorite scary movies of all time and
that's john carpenter's the thing
this is before computer generated
effects yeah everything
it's so good all practical
oh
i forgot how brutal this was just wait
dude
oh man it looks so good
oh my god look at that dude
look at that like i still can't believe
this dude looks so good disgusting
oh my gosh oh yeah so good look at that
such genius uses of fake floors and it's
like such perfect little tricks like
that's just a dude with a rod behind
like the desk moving the head around
it's super basic super big i mean the
models aren't basic oh that shot we just
forgot that shot just a little spider
head crawling away in the background and
then dude this when they turn around and
they're like what the heck i'm kidding
dude that's real fire they're actually
burning that prop yeah everything in
this movie is legit this movie was
filmed in 81 i think it came out in 82
and it looks so good because it's real
roboteen he was 19 years old i believe
when he did this whole movie all this
stuff had to be lit in a very specific
way for it to look real it was very dark
edge-lit and they had like a greasy gel
layer that they threw over top of
everything to give it that nice sheen
everything looks wet and gross yeah and
every single shot is like masterfully
composed in order to hide all the things
behind the scenes so this shot right
here right you have the two effects
artists underneath the table they're
puppeting the whole thing you have a guy
at the dummy's feet and he's you know
pulling some strings too and they're
pulling this head back and inside of the
head it's full of a bunch of different
melted plastic and bubble gum and
whatnot the little pus balloons that
fill up here yeah with like egg yolk it
looks like
what makes that shot powerful for me is
that it comes out of nowhere yeah you're
not expecting a chest to just open up
and then bite you it's a replica of this
dude's body even the head even the head
yeah because it tears off later oh
that's right it took about a month and a
half to build out this perfect sculpture
of this guy this replica so this guy
goes down boom they tear his stomach
open perfectly timed if you mess that up
you've just torn the stomach open of
your prop yeah they only have one take
of this they only do this once so his
hands get bit off and this is actually
an amputee they gave him fake arms bit
his fake arms off and he pulled back to
reveal just like his nubs and tear the
arms off oh man dude they get the
tearing of that fake skin yeah it's all
these little like masterful tricks going
into making this look real and keeping
it real it's just incredible this is
just a taste if you hadn't seen the
thing please go watch it because this is
just a taste of all the scenes in this
movie they're all this good they're
incredible so we'd be remiss if we
didn't pull up the 2011 thing i really
wanted to compare this
not all of us are human
let's put them over there on the couch
they got tormund dude tormund is that a
game of thrones servants
[Applause]
oh that's pretty cool so i'm looking at
this and i'm just like that little
monster does look pretty good for cgi
monster it's nice cgi like it's a great
looking cgi yeah no don't get me wrong
there's some pretty sweet moments in
this it's just a lot of it you can tell
is cg which takes you out of the movie
and for me if you were to compare the
two of course i gotta choose john
carpenter's version you know but that's
because john carpenter was like a master
filmmaker too 100 this leads to a very
common misconception in the world and
that is practical is better than cgi a
lot of people believe this and they
swear by it they're like it's always
better when you can do it practically
than using cgi or effects and it's like
that's not how it works at least from
what i've always kind of figured that
like a mixture of some practical stuff
augmented with effects is always better
than just effects or just practice and
that's what they were originally going
to do with this remake remake it was
mostly practical with some visual
effects adjustments after the fact oh
man that practical effect looks so good
look how gross this is look how much of
an effect this has on us right now just
watching this like reality documented
moment yeah so this i think studio adi
yeah they look so good all this
practical work that's insane i think it
was the studio and the producers who did
this they said it looks too much like an
80s movie so they went back and they
redid everything in cg i mean it that
doesn't look really good yeah no no no
it certainly does well they have the
best reference they hired a whole
special effects team and then just
covered up all the rewards that is true
so they are keeping parts of the
original footage now that i'm seeing
this breakdown they show like the cg
head the cg face but then they cover it
up with the real footage of the face my
take on cgi is this at the end of the
day cgi is a fancy cartoon you know it
can look really nice you can hit strong
emotions but it's still a quote-unquote
cartoon that's the effect that it has
versus a practical effect is more
theatrical it's more and i mean that
like the literal sense of being on a
stage it's a thing that's real that you
can hold in your hands and act with
there's a certain level of coordination
and authenticity that you definitely
don't get with cg authenticity that's
the key there i think and that's what a
lot of horror movies are is that
visceral reaction that you want to get
out of people at the end of the day we
know movies are fake there's a certain
amount of appreciating the art and you i
can appreciate good cg like i know what
goes into it like there's a lot of great
artistry there most people when they see
something that's real like a prosthetic
they can think of oh painting something
that like that would be hard yeah
sculpting that would be hard you get how
hard it would be and there's just a
matter of appreciating it go watch john
carpenter's the thing and then watch
this one and let us know what you guys
think down below in the comments which
film you preferred which film you were
more in on
you may have seen when we reacted to
birdemic and how awful those effects
were look at this dude it's like clip
art i was reading through the comments
on that video and there were a lot of
them that were saying that we should fix
the effects of that movie well guess
what we are doing it we're gonna make
bird democ kind of good so subscribe so
that you will be notified first thing
when that video drops in about a week
so this halloween this year is a little
bit different in that you know the whole
trick-or-treating thing probably isn't
going to happen quite the same way so if
you guys are staying home and watching a
spooky movie i hope you have fun if
you're having a couple friends over and
playing some spooky board games or
looking at each other's costumes i hope
it's cool and all i gotta say is it's
been an absolute pleasure making these
videos for you guys i really do enjoy
sitting on the couch with you guys doing
these videos it's coming to this
we're dressed up we're doing a halloween
episode we started this what a year and
a half now man wow good times everybody
it's been fun no it still is fun that
sounds like really morbid
well it's okay it's a little more but
it's halloween it is oh yeah good point
hey
if you don't subscribe i'll rip your
arms off
all right that's a good time for us to
end the video bye everybody see you
happy halloween